e
good morning I'm going to call together
the um subcommittee on um House Bill
1573 and I'm going to start by calling
on um Christa
Morris and um is Chris are you going to
have anyone else from the department
join you or
just okay just fine uh and we do have a
new Amendment and I've ask her to go
through that Amendment and um we have a
nice side by side which will be really
helpful for us thank you yes uh thank
you and I don't know if you need my name
but it's Christa Morris I'm with DHHS as
the Director of intergovernmental
Affairs um as you can tell hb1 1573 was
a bit complicated and so what we had to
do as I explained to you earlier um some
of the Amendments or some of the changes
in this amendment were merely a copy
paste issue with um all the back and
forth with the OCA we had a lot of edits
a lot of track changes and so when
things copy pasted over they didn't get
in so there are a few items in here that
that are that um and then there were
other changes that we worked with OCA on
to make technical amendments um just
kind of clarifying some language making
sure that the intent matches the
language or the language matches the
intent of the bill and then on top of
that we um added some language regarding
uh Juvenile Justice from
jrpg they had some edits just kind of
again word smithing changing some words
to meet the federal um requirements and
I'll go through them line by line I just
wanted to give a high high level and
then also there are some edits uh as
charged by representative Edwards
representative Pearson to try to uh
reduce the number of visits or anything
make changes that would possibly reduce
the fiscal impact to the department and
so all of those changes are in this
proposed amendment and we will go
through the six pages and just kind of
highlight some of those
okay thank
you all right so first we have strike
qualified qualified residential
treatment program um I think I explained
that last time that was just for some
facilities apply to be a qrtp qrtp yes
um make sure I got those letters correct
uh when you use letters would you would
you tell us what they stand for sure so
the qualified residential treatment
program we removed the queue from the
qrtp and that's only because that is a
federal uh designation if a facility
wants to apply for federal
uh title for foster care funding they
have to go through the qrtp process some
states do not engage in that process so
their their facilities in the state
wouldn't apply to be a qrtp doesn't mean
that that's a lower quality program it's
just a a funding mechanism title
essentially so we went through to make
sure that that didn't reduce the number
of facilities that we could send
children to and so we just wanted to
make sure that that was lined out
correctly
so next if you go to section one part
two that is under purpose and statements
so that's going to obviously have a zero
impact um it is some rewarding to again
oh I'm
sorry as um Miss Morris is going through
this uh because I've not seen this it
would be good if you could just give us
pause so I can read it before she starts
to explain it MH yep I can do that real
working
okay okay so again that's where we are
making sure that the language uh
reflects the intent of the bill prior uh
it it it was a broader statement so it
included many more youth placed in
residential facilities including those
that are voluntary youth you know their
parents send them versus the state and
so we wanted to make sure that this is
intended for children under the care of
the state and so that's why those
specific rsas are labeled in this bill
again $0 change
yeah I I think that would be easier
yeah so to understand the context of
this question let let me tell you where
I'm coming from um The Epiphany I had
the other day of about that whatever we
put into this law uh will open the state
up to lawsuit if we don't comply with it
uh has has just got me thinking that uh
we should uh try where we can to make
distinctions between uh shall and may uh
like later we're going to talk about
visits um and you know uh when we get to
that if it's a it's a we we shall do X
number I'm I'm wondering if we do um uh
we shall do a x which is a lower number
with an aspirational goal or we may do
as many as four so that there's shs that
set it down and ma that will will
definitely aim at from a budget
perspective in this instance on line
seven we use the word insure and ensure
feels like a good word to sue us because
if we don't and and and because it says
appropriate appropri we ensure
appropriate appropriate is a poorly
defined word and is subject to the
Judgment of a you potentially a jury or
a judge right so so I'm I'm
uncomfortable with the combination of
those two words in this sentence Ure
appropriate
so that's an observation Madam chair
thank
you and so that's one of those where I
noticed today on the Gen Court website
there are multiple dates for this bill
so um my goal is after today going
through this with you that these edits
these recommendations you make I will go
back with the OCA and and work out to
see what we can what we can do and and
of course that's just my opinion and and
the subcommittee would have to
take a position but that that's just my
personal first blush yeah let's let's
continue on with going through it and we
do want to get the response from um the
office of The troud Advocate and from
and from the court around um what they
see here and then we'll work on
wordsmithing it right yeah that's what I
me even though we love to
Wordsmith okay
so next we have section one Roman
four
and so this is where I'm going to call
in the OCA a little
bit some of these are your edits from
the
jrpg and so I can't speak to those as
well
unfortunately sorry I should have called
you up here to begin
with
yep
so if I could just nothing in this
finding section is a substantive change
in policy from what already passed
through the house like Christa mentioned
a little bit was just word smithing here
we added just two one partial sentence
in lines 12 and 13 a shortage or lack of
foster family homes or community- based
resources shall not be an acceptable
reason for placement in a residential
facility and that just helps this align
with the other pieces of the bill this
is mentioned other places so we just
wanted to make sure that was upfront in
the purpose and findings um and that
also aligns with some some federal
standards that you cannot put kids in a
more restrictive placement because a
residential facility is the most
restrictive placement just because you
have failed to provide less restrictive
resources so that really was just kind
of aligning the language throughout the
bill so this is a 1 a and 1B question
when you say there's no policy changes
and from what the house has done do do
you do you mean I I just want to be
clear we're not talking about the
current law we're talking about what
passed in 1573 previously as the as a
kind of a new policy correct okay in in
in this finding section so we are in
fact changing policy in order to get the
numbers to work so so um so we're going
to probably break some eggs along the
way here from what the house has already
passed as my guess
so the B part of
this is um as a as a person who has
worked in the real world if a shortage
of a resource if there is a shortage of
a resource it does obviously impact the
decisions that get made and so um
without understanding the stronger
context to this the fact that we're
saying a shortage or lack of Foster
family homes or community-based
resources shall not be an acceptable
reason I I I think by definition it
becomes an acceptable reason to come to
an alternative because you have no
resources so I I my my first instinct
would just be to strike that subp
paragraph what do you en sub paragraph
no no no from where it says a shortage
to the end where it says in a
residential facility I think shortages
are the real world and matter and I
think that a shortage of foster family
homes or Community Resources is not a
reason to take a
child's um freedoms and place them in a
very restriced facility that is intended
for short-term therapeutic
use if you don't have something you
can't use it that that seems fairly
obvious absolutely understandable that
the the shortage of resources does lead
to needing to take a look at alternative
placement options or we're saying here
is there's a difference between getting
creative with an alternative placement
option and putting a child in a setting
that is considered highly restrictive as
Lissa mentioned is the entire intention
of these facilities is to be providing a
therapeutic treatment and if that child
isn't in need of that therapeutic
treatment what are they gaining by being
in that facility and it could actually
become much more harmful and research
tells us can lead to more problematic
Behavior down the line if children
aren't in an appropriate setting from
the beginning of placement so so I don't
have a problem with anything you just
said other than this is written in the
negative this is saying Thou shalt not
and if you have a a good alternative
when we do not have these resources
could we write what a good alternative
would be so that we have uh an
affirmative direction to go instead of
um a reduction to a negative statement
the reason excuse me the reason an
alternative has not been provided in
writing here is we do not want to lock
them into one and only one option
alternative it is constantly evolving
the director of DCF has been getting
very creative around children where who
are coming into care where there is not
an option for placement and is not
immediately going to residential coming
up with other creative options maybe
adding additional services in other
areas to have a child plac there so
we're trying not to give them a one only
option we're trying to allow them the
freedom saying we can't move this child
to that restrictive setting but you have
the freedom to come up with other
creative options and that's constantly
evolving currently month by month we're
having new um Alternatives that we're
that the state agency is coming up with
to get creative around placement of
children and I would also just point out
since we are in finance um residential
facilities are exponentially more
expensive per day than any other type of
placement as well as I I heard you
mentioned liability earlier you know you
do open yourself up when you're putting
children in placements that are not
appropriate for them that are more
restrictive that are traumatic for them
so I I think and also part of the word
smithing was this is language that
aligns with current federal Court
standards about placement of children um
so as well as Federal funding the family
first Prevention Services act which
provides funding to the states if
they're utilizing Residential Care
appropriately then they can receive
additional funding to to miss sanz's
point about there being creativity and
Alternatives and some smart things we
can do uh there's nothing uh in this
paragraph from lines 10 to 18 that are
suggestive of what might be done in lie
of in in the presence of a shortage and
and if we could have some language in
here uh to explain what sort of
Alternatives or thought process would be
appropriate I think that would be useful
to the to the
bill your words were great they're just
not in the bill so that's what I'm
saying I think they heard what you were
saying and let's move on maybe Christa
can move to the next section
sure so next if you on the amendment
line 19 Section one room and numeral 6
uh I believe this was more word smithing
to
align time out read
yep sorry about
that
e
ready
okay we'll come back to that one oh
we're going to come back to that one
okay because I'm going through copy
pasted so I'm
wondering sorry if I could I think it
adds and oversight process the first
sentence y thank you I think we're a
little too In The Weeds on it so we're
just so the modifications is line 21 it
added and oversight process yes
okay and
let's I think we've got that one let's
move move on to the next session oh you
have't okay representative Edwards has a
question thank you madam chair so on
line 26 we specifically say effective 6
months later and uh is is it the
Department's position that creating the
job descriptions creating the structure
doing the hiring the availability of
potential Workforce that all of those
factors that go go into building this
can be done in six
months if we work really hard it could
happen in six months um I spoke to our
finance so right now um governor and
council is going on so our Chief
Financial Officer Nate naan he's over
there he will come over here afterward
um but he explained you know between
getting through Das or you know to get a
position number to get it posted to get
all of those
steps we might have someone hired in six
months yeah because I'm I'm still
paranoid about the litigation potential
and and so I I would be more comfortable
with a a kind of an uh
aspirational versus um uh a drop dead
date if I may respond to that from from
the OC excuse me from the OCA
perspective um we do understand it will
take additional positions to fulfill
this fully but there are positions that
currently exist that are in this role so
they need additional positions but there
are folks about two or three that are
already doing the certification so it's
not that you're building a completely
new division you're adding bodies to the
division which over time um can be done
and I do believe that six Monon time
frame is achievable for that and then it
will just add to the number of them that
can get out and see these facilities we
also disagree about the number of
positions necessary frankly in this this
bill the way it is currently written the
OCA believes that two to three positions
in BCB should cover it there should not
need to be any more positions in dcyf
related to monthly visits we haven't
really gotten to talk to the court in
depth but we and this is why we came
that we believe that the request is far
overreaching and really truly
unnecessary to even meet what was passed
in the house um and so we we did
disagree that there would need to be any
additional time the six months should be
enough to build out two or three more
positions in bcbh um and I hear uh
representative Edwards your concerns
about
liability from a legal standpoint and I
have been an attorney for dcyf as well
as a parent side attorney so I've done
both sides of this work I think the
release of the bledo report in all the
conversations that have occurred last
summer last fall at the policy
committees in both the House and Senate
there's already a liability issue
because the frankly the division is
really already required to do almost
everything that is in this bill already
and it was not being done to the
standard that was protecting children so
I hear your concerns about liability but
I think just having had these
conversations that liability is already
there now thank you so so I can
appreciate that but I'm not going to
contribute to making it easy here for
somebody to go go against the state with
by putting it into law uh I I I'm I
don't want to do that so
um okay go ahead yeah thank you so much
okay let's move on
okay so the last row on page one starts
on line 29 of the
amendment and that
was so there is an well the addition was
already passed we are removing a
strikeout and I'll let you read that but
removing the strikeout for
exemption
so so is it so in effect does this make
it easier to uh for the state to find a
placement
option no I don't believe so this this
came from our chief legal officer that
she did not want that struck out um and
it what it's an exemption from
inspections so if we if we have to do
fewer inspections uh doesn't it follow
then that it it's easier for us to find
an alternative facility because we don't
have to subject it to an inspection
process that that that's I'm wondering
what the Practical implication of
removing that as a strike out
is honestly from our point of view we
felt that the new bold
language at the end of that paragraph
created the same requirements that's why
that other piece was struck out I know
dcyf legal disagreed and I I would defer
to them but I I believe we are chief you
guys have so many titles Chief legal I
understand they they felt but I think
the purpose of the new bold language was
to capture those same sort of oversight
there was just in different statutes
based on what was newly written but I I
believe it should be similar it was just
spreading the duty across because some
of these new
sections because you have you have zero
yeah
so I will explain this one real quickly
to you on line seven of page two that
was originally RSA 170 and we changed it
to one uh the department feels it it
fits better under 169 and so that's why
that change is
made yes
well good okay so then next we have
section three Roman 1 and that starts on
line 10 or line yes 10 of page
two this is ensuring and it again it's I
think this is more word smithing it's
making sure that any program does not
receive funding from us if they are not
certified and that we do not send
children there if they are not
certified it's and it's just some word
smithing to make sure that that aligns
the the facility must you
know meet the requirements so it also
clarifies that all facilities where
children are placed must also be
licensed if they're in New Hampshire
they're licensed under New Hampshire
170e if they're out of state they're
still required to be licensed but it's
by that State's licensing body so that
clarification it also took out um outof
State programs and just made any program
because it doesn't matter if they're in
state or out of state they need to be
licensed and they need to be certified
so that was just a little bit of cleanup
language there so so that's intentional
going from 13 to 14 where it uh says by
the department so there's no other
certification alternative other than the
state doing the certification which is
current law that's intentional correct
is current law right now yes that's good
thanks so then next it says new two
sections three Roman numeral 2 and three
Roman numeral 3 that's where I explained
earlier there was a track changes copy
paste error I just needed to add those
sections back in to the law
um it creates a new certification team
which is what we were discussing earlier
as well as we shall develop a standard
operating procedure and a form that we
will consult with the child
advocate um and this is what I spoke to
I think
some of you before uh we have invited
the OCA to Shadow us on visits for
certification and DCF visits so that way
they can um kind of see what we do but
then also provide feedback if there's
anything they want us to add to our
checklist add to what we look at during
those
visits
so on line 25 of page two this is now
section 4 it was previously three Roman
numeral
2 this is again I believe just kind of
expanding some of the language priorly
mentioned or priorly is that a word
mentioned prior um regarding just
ensuring that the facility is licensed
and in their own State and that they are
Li in an instate facility they are
licensed by us and that everyone is
certified by us and that's not a change
that this is it's the same as what was
passed by the house in
February so question there uh is there
is there a break glass option on this if
we really need to do a placement and we
don't have time to complete the
certification is there an emergency
workaround I believe our team dis
batches
emergency uh staff to go and quickly
certify a facility before placing a
child there so we never send a child
that is to a facility that is not
previously certified it just may happen
in short order our team dispatches I
don't know same day next day and they go
and and certify it before we send a
child there because we cannot pay them
unless they are a certified facility
they are not going to take our child
without knowing that they're going to
get paid for it thanks that's a complete
answer thank you and just to add to that
since we were talking about lack of
resources there are a number of
facilities currently that are certified
and do not have any children placed in
them so in an emergency they have beds
that are already certified that they
have the ability to outreach and utilize
that too
yeah all right so next we have on start
starting on line 32 of page two now
section Roman numeral 5 what was
previously
three so this is where I know the OCA
will not agree with this is the attempt
to reduce the requir uh the visit
requirements from four times per year to
at least two per year and I say at least
so that way our staff also has that
flexibility if I call it their Spidey
senses start going off they can go back
and do another facility visit um and one
of those visits so one will be the
regular certification visit and then the
other one will be unannounced to the
facility it will be a Popin spot check
well but broader than a check
yeah and presently they're doing they're
required to do one one per year yes so
this doubles it doubles what is
currently being done but it cuts it in
half by what was recommended um and this
would obviously reduce the fiscal impact
by that but then also again gives us
that flexibility to go out more
frequently than just to if needed thank
you represent uh thank you uh so would
it um help bring OCA and the department
together if we inserted a new sentence
that said something about the department
making good faith efforts to do as many
as four a year so that we we so that we
remove the distinction between what
we're legally obligated to do and what
we want to do aspirationally could we
could we add a sentence uh there about
um the department making good faith
efforts to do more than the
two currently they're you know required
to do twice per year
including and I think one unannounced is
that a part of the
two the new language that's what it
would be it would be so just two okay
great but at a minimum
we would endorse more than
two we we requested corly I I think just
to bring to the Forefront and and we
didn't get to give sort of the context
and background to this bill to begin
with a discovery that was made after the
bledo incident was that in fact the
required annual visits were
often I'm going to take back often we
don't know but we know they weren't
always being done at all so potentially
we're going from zero V which is
dangerous to but we we're trying to get
data on that we've requested data on
exactly what was happening to try and
get a
baseline the other issue I think and and
going back to the building out of the
certification team this is one of the
places where the OCA really has an issue
with the fiscal request of they
requested eight new positions to build
that certification team currently
they're an agency of eight so they want
to double the size of their agency to do
visits that are actually already
required because they weren't doing them
always now we had discussed last fall
that two to three more people would be
appropriate in addition we have data on
the number of children in placements and
the number of certified placements what
we don't have is the number of certified
placements where there are currently
children because this only requires them
to do more than once a year visits to
places where children physically are at
that moment so again it seems to be an
overblown number and we've been asking
for the specific numbers of okay so we
know there's 264 children placed under
dcyf care in New Hampshire facilities DC
was 228 228 sorry we know there are 32
certified facilities in New Hampshire
what we don't know is how many of those
facilities have those 228 kits
presumably in New Hampshire probably all
32 in New England there's 28 certified
facilities only 56
kids 56 children placed by
dcyf there's 28 certified facilities we
do not believe there are children at all
28 which means you're not visiting all
28 under this either version whether
it's four times a year or twice a year
and then outside of New England so this
is the big one when you start looking at
section eight the appropriation for
travel there's actually only three dcyf
youth placed outside of New England we
knew um two ones in Arkansas ones in
Florida there are also some voluntarily
placed youth so bcbh would be visiting
those facilities but there's 24
certified facilities outside New England
certainly five children are not at 24
facilities so again we're struggling to
get accurate data of where exactly
people are going to have to go you're
telling us you need eight more people
and almost a million dollars to go visit
when we know that it's a much smaller
universe so that's where we're
struggling with the appropriation piece
because we just think it does not line
up with what this bill actually requires
we would love there to be quarterly
visits two a year is better than zero a
year they should have already budgeted
for one a
year yes yes would it be appropriate
then just to online 32 and 33 put at
least two twice a year and one
unannounced if
needed we would say the unannounced is
always needed okay but we'd love that
three would be great better than two
yeah so I I would be so I would not
support that though I I I would rather
have the minimum language as the shall
and and I asked a question earlier that
I don't think has been addressed would
it plate the department if we inserted
some good faith language to say that
that the number of inspect inpections
the department shall make best efforts
or good faith efforts to do uh three or
four a year so so I'm trying to make a
distinction between what we can be sued
over and what we can build policy and
budgets
around that I'm I'm I'm trying to help
the department and the OCA by finding a
middle ground approach here could I
could I just ask the department a
question so if you go out and make um
your the one visit a year and during
that
visit
um the person doing the visiting from
the department has some concerns but
they don't really rise to the level of
that um the child advocate found in the
Tennessee facility but they now can go
back to that facility and do as many
visits as they deem or they need to do I
believe so y yeah I um but I mean we
also have written in here a corrective
action plan as well for the facility to
come up to speed okay okay and then do
you go back and follow up with that
corrective action plan to be sure they
actually did it do you want to grab a
mic pull up a
mic oh please don't knock why isn't
everybody just bring their chair up I
know everybody come
upstairs
um good morning Rebecca Ross from Thea
uh Bureau for children's Behavioral
Health currently what happens is we go
out um once a year the certification
runs for two years one year is the
certification visit the following year
is the technical assistance quality
assurance visit um the the function of
the visit is always the same to look at
the facility to interview youth to
interview staff to check records and go
through things it is more comprehensive
on the 2-year certification if there's
something identified on either one there
is um the certification or the visit
report a corrective action plan and then
a back and forth with the facility to
ensure that they are following up and
then the next time they are on site
they're also checking in on that it
really depends on what it is if it's
something with the facility and we need
eyes on to see it or it's update this
document or update this policy some of
the corrective action items are very
easily done from the office and we're
not on sign other things we would need
to be on site we certainly have the
ability to go onsite at any time we do
not have the resources currently we have
three people that do all of the
residential Contracting visits technical
assistance collaboration management of
individual kids eligibility for
voluntary cases and a number of other
responsibilities so they are on the
certification team but they are
certainly not exclusive to that um
they've made three out of state visits
in the last 3 to four weeks one
individual is in Atlanta today there are
times that we are going to a place to
certify it and then the placement falls
through so even though there are only
five kids we are still working with 10
to 15 facilities at any time to either
bring them on board or do a visit to see
if a youth can go so there's a lot of
back and forth and a lot of uncertainty
on the visits that need to be done thank
you question
um so again my understanding you have
currently you have 21
28 in the New England area 24 outside
the New England area are you doing
certifications each
year we are not doing the on-site visit
but we are doing the certification
process to keep them on the roles if
they want to continue to be a certified
provider some are very unique specific
providers that we may not never have a
youth in the next couple years but then
three years from now we do so the
question is yes okay thank you if I
could just add that I appreciate your
question representative priest um just a
couple things so if you look at the next
page line six of Page Three and this
this has essentially been in here the
entire time through all the
iterations as of the adoption of this
bill there will not be placements
outside of New England without specific
director approval one of the main
reasons for this bill is we need to keep
children closer to their homes and their
families so the 24 outside of New
England hopefully won't be used at all
anymore um I would also point out that
the certification process currently on
the books in administrative rule does
require the certification to be in
person but sounds like that is not
currently happening um we had proposed
language in this new section uh Roman
five because they're only visiting
places where New Hampshire children are
um we had requested language be added
that if they are proposing to place a
child there even if it's already
certified there needs to be an imperson
visit if nothing if there hasn't been an
inperson visit within 90 days because
now you're saying if was certified
January 1st of
2023 and it's now December 15th 2023
you're potentially going to send a kid
there having not and now I'm hearing
that if there wasn't a kid there and
they recertified they didn't visit at
all so now when was the last time
someone's eyes was on this facility
because who knows what's going on there
so again and the oca's job is to protect
children obviously we are always
thinking about best interest the trauma
the harm what potentially could be
happening because while we caught what
was Happ happening at
bledo there's a lot of information out
there that it's not just bledo that that
bad things are happening maybe not to
that degree hopefully but but some
places yes so having eyes on
facilities frequently and certainly
before you put a kid there is important
but we have seen the bureau go out and
emergency certify a placement they
actually just did it in Virginia this
past month um so they do have that
capacity we're hearing that there's two
or three people that do it now that's
why we're proposing this new team be two
to three dedicated people that that is
all they're doing because it is a it is
a lift well and if I may add in this we
too are thinking about the potential for
lawsuits and are thinking that these are
actually a protection against that
because if you're there you're seeing
what's happening you've gathered the
information and know what's going on
hopefully and and more frequently that
would be caught before a child is
further traumatized which would lead to
somebody taking out a lawsuit next state
so that is an attention in there is a
lawsuit do diligence was done a
reasonable person
standard was
met question again um are you in
constant contact with the other states
and their certification problems so if a
facility like in Virginia suddenly
becomes desertified for whatever reason
do they communicate that to you so
you're on top of it and you don't put a
child there if it's not certified by
that state
you yes we absolutely do when we're
doing the recertification process we're
reaching out to the other states the
providers have an obligation to let us
know and we certainly have a
relationship with the home state of
those providers as we're going through
the process so is it possible that
something could happen one day and we
don't learn that exact day absolutely I
think things can can always happen but
yes that is certainly part of our
process and part of their obligation to
let us know if their licensing status
changed
and even from a child advocate point of
view so when bledo occurred and we
issued our report we we have a network
of other child advocacy offices we
certainly broadcast that across the
country of this we just found this at
this facility to put other child
advocate offices on notice I know bcbh
desertified bledo after a couple of
months I don't know how that network
works but there is certainly
communication so thank you madam chair I
I just have three points related to
lines 32 through
36 first uh o overall I I just want to
say I think everyone in this room shares
the uh desire to protect all of our
children so it so OCA that's obviously
your primary Charter but I don't want to
leave it hanging in the air that the
rest of us don't care as much as you do
about kids okay so so I I want to get
that out there um um uh and what you
were saying about going and visiting
like I'll call it a stale certification
whatever we Define as stale you know uh
going and double-checking it before we
place a kid there to make sure that we
know what the current situation is if
that's new language in here I'm I'm I'm
personally okay with that and then for
the third time I want to ask the
question and try to get an answer on the
third time miss Morris I'll ask you
specifically uh would it be helpful if
we kept the language in 32 and 33 of at
least twice per year one of which is an
unannounced visit and added a sentence
to talk about an aspirational goal or a
good faith effort to do more than that
would that would would that would that
be beneficial to the policy and
budgeting process
I think it really depends on what you
want as a result of that visit it is if
it's merely it's the same thing as every
other visit that's my objective is it
would be the same as every other visit
but instead of being required in law we
would be doing it because we think it's
good policy as opposed to good law and I
see a distinction between what we put in
law and what we try to do with our
Department's uh work effort so so I
think from our perspective a unannounced
announced visit is going to be very
different and provide very different
results than an announced visit because
there is a lot of scheduling in advance
work to pulling files and scheduling
with staff and making sure the right
people are on site and available
including Youth and sending out surveys
to parents and families and other staff
in advance to prep for that visit so
when we're doing our announced visit
there's a ton of prep work if we're
doing an unannounced visit we may not
see any New Hampshire youth that could
be on a field trip day um we will really
only be able to walk in talk to whoever
may be available and have time for us
and see the facility and not get those
same outcomes so if we only want one of
the structured visits per year and the
other one to be un announc that language
would be fine if we want two visits per
year that are structured and have that
same kind of report out then we would
need a third unscheduled visit okay so
I'm going to take that as a yes to my
question yes adding a sentence dealing
with good faith efforts to do more than
the minimum required would be helpful
what you just went into is a tremendous
amount of detail about the nature of
those additional good faith visits and
that's fine figure that out but I'm just
trying to make sure that the OCA
realizes we're we're hearing them that
more is more better but I don't want to
obligate the state to something that we
we may not be able to achieve in in in
two 3 four years for now this is going
to be the Hot Topic and we're going to
get on this and we're going to fix it
but the legislator in three or four
terms they're going to have different
priorities different issues and I I want
the law to be able to
breathe um in response to that um I was
wondering if represented the
representative uh would agree to uh on
line 32
to um keep the wording at least twice
per year and one unannounced visit so
there' be three total at least three I
I'm I'm not interested in doing that
from a mandatory going from two to three
that's 50% more visits I just assume
right now we're having zero I so we're
doing better already right because we're
already at two right so so I I I would
like like to keep and maybe I'm not
making myself clear because of the
litigation risk I'd rather keep Our
obligation under the law
limited and I'm totally okay with them
doing more than what we legally obligate
with this sentence that I keep talking
about a a good faith the department
shall make good faith so so so
representative priest I I I hear you and
I think the way to get there is by
adding a good faith sentence yeah again
my concern is with that in good faith is
hard to budget for that so if a case
comes up and they have to come out more
than an additional one maybe twice visit
because they see problems in it then
it's hard they'll be over their budget
so so so on the budgeting I I've I've
sat through two budgets on
DHHS and I I I don't think that it's
particularly difficult for the
Department to come up with what they
think their good faith effort would be
and then be subjected to division 3
questioning you know what what's what
what's really required here versus what
you're trying to do and then that allows
the division three people of the future
to um allocate resources that are
available for allocation I so so I get
your point about budgeting but having
done two of them and and represented
Wallner has done a million of them uh I
not a million I I I I don't think that
that's the
roadblock and if I could just point
something out that I think helps support
your point representative Edwards
always and I did not mean to imply other
people here don't want to protect
children we're lucky that that's our
sole Focus we don't have to talk about
all the other stuff um so in line 36 I I
will note that an additional protection
here is that previously the records uh
resulting from those visits by the BCB
certification team only went to the
facility so we add here that they also
come to our office um we've been asking
for these records for some time if the
OCA gets those site visits not only do
you have bcbh on it you have OCA eyes on
it to also potentially pick up on issues
to bring to the Forefront um so that's
another level of protection built in as
well as um the next section we're going
to talk
about by increasing not the frequency
but the recording of those monthly dcyf
caseworker visits that already happens
again more reporting more eyes more
potential for those additional
non-mandatory visits to potentially
happen so so so I'm good with that uh I
I think the balance is you know uh you
know privacy and administrative overhead
with uh TR transparency and the need to
know clearly the OCA has a need to know
and is able to handle the privacy issues
so having access to the reports I think
that's great I just wouldn't want to be
sloppy about who else starts to get them
because I think there's sensitive
information in there right 100% in our
statute everything is completely
confidential so that is the place to
have that exercise
eyes so next on page three line six of
the amendment uh this changes the
language of no placement out this is
what Lisa spoke to earlier regarding uh
no placement out of region shall occur
after January 1 however this our
proposed Lang anguage is that no
placement outside of New England shall
occur without the approval of Jeff our
our DCF director um he should have eyes
and and know who who is being sent out
of
regen
okay improv that that's an excellent
Improvement I just wonder uh if somebody
was filling in as an interim would this
law allow an interim to act or the and
yes I was yes it
does so moving on to line 11 of Page
Three this is again the OCA will not
agree with this and I I understand line
yes you agree with line 11 and
12 um however down to line 20 not as
much
um so the reason I'll start at the top
we this is again limiting the number or
the
the the categories I guess of which the
children fall under as to who we go and
visit and that is 169 b c and
d we will see them or our staff will see
them at least on a monthly basis um
however as if you and I know you're
going to read this but if you look at
how it was proposed versus how it looks
now we removed essentially a lot of the
checklist that was in the the language
and it would move to a checklist that we
would work with the OCA on but it's not
in statute and some of that is because
we did have concerns with um some of the
language it required leadership meet
with us
and you know the definition of
leadership the the definition of uh who
would be called leadership and then
also requiring a third party to to meet
with us so we wanted to make sure that
it allowed us some some leniency on who
we met with and who we felt was
appropriate to meet with and I say we
the the real people doing the real work
um but so and I'll let you read
that okay on line 17 the use of the
forras safe place is mentioned uh who
who determines uh what a safe place is
and does that beg to be
defined so I'm not a subject matter
expert on that I would assume that would
be the case worker and the youth would
kind of the youth is so so when you guys
go away and and rework some of these
comments would you would you just have a
conversation about whether or not this
should be more clear about who makes a
determination of a safe place I I I I'm
okay with the concept the place should
be safe but it leads to the question of
well who makes the determination does
the does the patient say I don't feel
safe in this place and even though it's
safe I mean I just want some clarity
there um I I agree with the concept and
then and then the second part of that is
um I you and I had talked earlier and I
I I I suggested that perhaps we could
insert some language that would allow
video conferencing
um and there's no video conference
mentioned in here and and there's a
reason for not having it I'm sure there
is um however I am going to swap
out can I just respond respond to the
first first piece that you pointed out
here about the safe space um I conduct
these visits on behalf of the OCA with
my staff as well so my staff go out and
conduct visits and meet with children
that's how we uncovered bled so in doing
those and this is the reason why this
language is in here here and the
expectation of a social worker would be
to meet with a child and say I'm looking
to have a confidential conversation with
you where you can speak to me openly
about what is happening for you in this
program said worker brings them to a
conference room when they sit down in
this conference room do you feel this is
a place that you can share openly with
me or are you concerned that others will
overhear a conversation and we need to
relocate to somewhere else so that is
when defining that safe space that
conversation should be happening before
they go into detail about how that child
is doing at the very onset of the
visit I'm just I'm just saying I'd like
I I I think this BS the possibility of
needing to be uh clear on who makes the
determination the final determination
that the place is safe so that they can
go ahead and do the interview and uh and
I open the question are there any
standards that we should mention around
what a what view depending on if it's a
juvenile case or a child protection case
is meeting in person with the child in a
place that they have worked together
before coming out to reserve to have a
private room set up in case you know if
if a roommate is present in the room
some place where they can meet with the
child in a safe secure for both parties
for everyone to feel open and uh ready
to have these open transparent
conversations so that's already
occurring in
policy this is a another question for
the department so the case workers are
going out and monthly and they do that
now is that correct they go monthly the
facilities to all the facilities and the
foster
homes to meet with the children so if if
there's no children in that facility no
the casew worker in the jppo is going
out in person to the res the residential
placement where the child is located yes
to meet with
them what happens if they go
out and they have a concern to meet with
the child and they have a concern about
the facility
how does that interact with the
certification um staff do they come can
do they have an obligation to come back
and report that they felt something
was not right
um what what's the interaction there
since they are going out
monthly sure and there's many layers to
that so each child who is played say out
of state is also under the confines of
either ICPC or icj so there's an
interstate compact in which there is a
home state uh juvenile probation system
as well as a child protection system so
if it was something um about that
Resident placement they would alert the
local CPS local JJ as to what is
occurring in that location if it's about
the child themselves so yeah they would
also in addition to uh alerting the
local Child Protection Agency
of the state where the of the placement
facility is they would also alerting the
case itself here in New Hampshire so the
the worker would alert their their
supervisor if necessary they would call
for an immediate exp parte a phone call
to the judge for an emergency hearing on
the placement of this child so there's
many safety precautions and safety
um
uh reactive um means to make sure that
everyone knows that there's something
going on in this facility even if it's
not related to the child
itself I do want to clarify um the ICPC
process the ICPC process does not assign
a social worker from the state that the
child's in to do monitoring visits if
the child's in residential that only
stands if the child is placed in a
foster home um so icj is separate for
juvenile justice but for ICPC placements
the New Hampshire would be the sending
State the receiving state would only
assign if that child is in a home
setting if they're in a residential
setting the cpsw from the state of New
Hampshire is still the assigned case
worker they are responsible for going
out for those in-person visits to the
child and it is as mentioned as um Susan
mentioned it is in current policy
current dcif policy that they are to
immediately alert their supervisor um
but it does not there is no clear chain
of command beyond alerting their
supervisor in that policy so as we speak
here about developing a standard
operating procedure that are some those
are some of the pieces that we would
look to make a bit more clear how does
that messaging then get over to the bcbh
team and not just live with that worker
and that supervisor well and
representative Walmer I think your
question gets actually to the heart of
the purpose of this bill and sort of
what came out of bledo the discovery was
made that those worker visits so again
we talked about sort of the buckets
there's the BCB certification team
visits that's about CER the facility
there are these dcyf or jppo worker
visits which are there assigned to that
kid and then the court oversight piece
we haven't gotten to yet but so what was
is happening or at least was happening
in some places including bledo the
worker assigned to the child
went 15minute visit laid eyes on that
child in a little conference room didn't
see any part of the facility didn't talk
to anybody else at the facility and that
was the issue that how would they have
seen all the red flags that the OCA saw
because they literally walked in walked
into a conference room 15 minutes eyes
on that kid K everything's great got
back on an airplane so that's why this
piece of the bill is so important and
why the original language is so crucial
and why this amendment essentially
undermines the entire purpose of the
bill to avoid visits happening like that
anymore if you're just going to see a
kid potentially one you've never even
met before say you know how how are you
doing how's your permanency plan how's
your education how's your treatment good
good and then don't actually talk to the
treatment provider don't talk to the
direct service staff that's actually
with this kid all day don't talk to any
other person or adult in that facility
that's where these things happen that's
where your liability is in a foster home
they go in they talk to the foster
parents they talk to the other kids in
the home they're going to talk to the
teacher the therapist
you know so this is really intended to
mirror the level of contact and
information you're Gathering about a
particular child who is on your case
load into that residential setting
because the Direct Care staff is like
the foster parent the leadership is
setting the rules the therapist is the
therapist so that's the very heart of
this bill and I'm glad that you asked
that question because that is the
problem with way things work now and why
we felt it's so important that it needs
to be a lot clearer in law because the
policy already says that stuff but
that's not what was happening well and
and to make sure it's clear um for those
who maybe haven't had an opportunity to
read the full bledo report there were as
Lisa mentioned workers that had gone out
once a month for the entirety of the
placement of the two children that we
met with and not one concern was
documented in their case record not one
about this facility and if you read the
the lengthy concerns that we were able
to observe in one visit we're noticing
that the the visits that are happening
by the workers right now are not
capturing the same level of
information are the case workers
required to yes meet with the child in
a safe place are they also required to
see where the child the child's sleeping
Arrangement at every
visit yes they tour the living quarters
of that child as well as all common
areas that that child um goes on a
day-to-day basis whether it the library
the gym the
cafeteria um and again if we're I guess
we're now moving on to I thought we were
still talking about just the safe place
but it appears that we're talking also
about the the visit itself the reason
why we had concerns about what was
labeled in the visit um in the original
1573 was a lot of shells a lot of shells
that were beyond the control of the
casew worker and put the casew worker in
a position of being being a quality
assurance
um representative which they're not um
of course when they're in the facility
their heads need to be on a swivel they
need to be taking notice of everything
that is going on in that facility but
there were a lot of shells that were
beyond their control such as tour of the
entire facility each time they go every
30 days they need to tour the entire
facility Way Beyond just the facility of
the uh portion that the child is so if
it's a co-ed they be look at you know
acres and Acres of property that is
beyond what is their child's needs what
their child is exposed to on a daily
basis they would be shall discussed with
leadership the program culture and
therapeutic program they shall have
discussions with the program Direct Care
staff they shall have discussions with
the Clinical Director and or therapeutic
provider about the program
culture therapeutic programming so again
things that go beyond just the what's
going on with the child things about the
entire facility which again is putting
us we feel in a liability issue in terms
of the the shells that are involved and
that's why in our in our Amendment it
was much more talking about the child
itself themselves right discussing their
treatment their education their
transition um
planning and what is also already
occurring which occurs either live in
like through a teams or through written
correspondence is updates is being part
of their therapeutic treatment uh
meetings talking with the clinical
placement provider speaking with the
therapeutic providers and educational
providers preferably in real time but at
least by written correspondence as
opposed to the original bill which said
that all of that was happening in person
during that 30-day uh tour because
sometimes those program meetings are not
at the same time as that 30-day uh
meeting with the child so they're
focusing on the child at that 30-day
visit and then in in addition of that
they're being involved in the treatment
team meetings whether it be by teams or
through written correspondence through
email so that's much more than just that
30-day visit however the way the bill
was written everything was to occur
during that 30-day visit is why the um
fiscal bill was so high in regards to
first it was the cas worker each 30 days
so that would require them to be uh at
these locations for multiple days in
order to be meeting with uh you know
leadership the program Direct Care staff
uh The Clinical Director the therapeutic
provider so again the there were there
were a lot of shells in that original
Bill and so if if you look at the
amendment that you all had last Monday
that was agreed upon language between
the o CA in the department last week
that had vastly different language
including agreed upon language limiting
the facility visit to just be parts of
the facility that the child had access
to because we understood how they could
misread that language and cut down some
of it and this is completely new and
different stripped down language that
frankly doesn't even rise to the level
of what is supposed to be happening now
and the problem is that stuff was not
not happening the seven visits to bledo
were in a tiny little conference room
they did not see where the children
slept or they would have seen that they
were on mattresses on the floor um so we
appreciate that there is a balance but I
find it very difficult to understand how
talking to Direct Care staff who's
providing the direct care to the child
about how that kid is doing and what the
the milu culture the millu is sort of
the common space where children are all
day doesn't relate directly to that
child's care that's not a facility visit
you're asking about the programming the
discipline the education that that
particular child is being provided by
those people you are talking directly to
so is it your position that this
language includes all that smart Common
Sense inspection it is our understanding
that it's not happening now and if it's
not clarified in language it's going to
continue to not occur so I would argue
that that's an assumption right I mean
that that that that's an assumption but
is there anything in this language that
precludes the common sense inspection
that you're saying is required I believe
we're missing a lot of of really
pertinent information I mean as simple
as the discussion around the treatment
team meetings that workers are to be
engaging in our office received a notice
within the past two weeks that workers
are not attending those meetings on a
regular basis it is to be assumed that
they should be it is by Statute and and
I'm not sorry by Statute by policy that
they should be attending them it is not
happening so again without that shall
and by leaving something with a May or
by pulling out the substance of it it
may be an assumption that it's not going
to happen but I also cannot assume it is
going to happen I do not have enough
evidence of be current behavior by the
cpsws that this is what is actually
going to occur and I just I wanted to
point out to that the one part of this
that was agreed to was that change to
the first section uh spe specifying that
these are only for court ordered
placements under 169 b c and d which are
already monthly visits that are
currently happening already by taking
out episode of treatment that should
eliminate any new positions necessary or
any new travel funds necessary because
as has been repeatedly stated these
monthly visits by case workers and jppo
under BC and D already happened are
already happening are already budgeted
for the travels already happening um the
the
additional conversations that were in
the original Bill and frankly even the
amendment you got last week which was
agreed upon language that the OCA
approved um really should not increase
we're not asking them to do a facility
visit at all and I went to Florida a
couple months ago when we walked in it
was a member of leadership who walked us
to see the kid you go see the kid it's a
direct service staff who's standing
right there it's not like we're asking
them to sit down for hours with
PowerPoints when you go into a facility
to see a child you are naturally and
normally going to interact there's
always a member of leadership present
unless you're visiting in the middle of
the night which I presume they're not
doing there's always a member of
therapeutic team on site it's a
residential facility the children are
secluded there every single person they
interact with it's a 247 staffed
facility it's not the I think the way
it's being explained is again
overreaching of really what OCA was
asking for in the original bill that
passed even in last week's Amendment
this strips out everything and just
leaves it to policy which we know is
currently not being followed and is not
protecting
children would you point out in the
amendment from last week exactly what
the were the agreed Bond language
is yeah I got to be honest I didn't read
last week's Amendment knowing that we
were going to be doing representative
Pearson's Amendment so I I'm looking at
0980 8 Z is that we on the same
Amendment yes that should be yeah so
this was language that we had all
hammered out
together uh previously it is
page two no page two
yeah
section
three line n line 20 so starting at line
20 to line 33 Okay is the language we
all agreed on together after multiple
meetings except for taking out just in
line 21 or placement for an episode of
treatment so that would have pulled in
bcbh voluntarily placed kids and would
have required additional people for sure
we took that out no additional people
should be needed these visits are
happening and this language was in fact
compromised language it is less than
what was in the original bill as passed
by the house we sat and had a productive
conversation about where you know the
entire facility versus what's
accessible but still
includes all of these important pieces
of information that the worker should
gather this directly relates to that
child in that placement and this
language today totally different we've
never seen it till an hour ago and does
not address the issues that were
discovered and are
occurring so part of this in so the
reason there is a difference she is
correct we agreed upon that language but
it was with the but now with the charge
of trying to reduce some of the the
fiscal burden we remove that section
because a we can add it to the cons the
the form in consultation with the with
the OCA that's in the next section but
then also it allows for some flexibility
to determine who we should meet with
versus shall meet with these people we
can we can manipul not manipulate we can
determine and to deem who is appropriate
to meet with also some of these
discussions could be had over the phone
and not in person necessarily so that's
why we just removed it so that we could
add it to the form to meet consultation
with the OCA and then also as I stated
earlier we have asked that they you know
Shadow some of our visits so that they
can say hey maybe you should look at
this and look at that as well so we
aren't trying to Sher the
responsibilities we're trying to make
sure our staff aren't there just okay I
met with this person okay you know
they're really having meaningful
conversations and they're able to drive
that based on what they are experiencing
at the facility and not beholden to a
checklist in in a statute and in all
cander yes if this amendment is agreed
upon the fiscal note for the travel will
basically go down to zero I mean because
we are doing this on a monthly basis if
it goes from Shell to May when it comes
to talking with the leadership and the
providers in a way that can be done at a
later time but within that month span
during Zoom a zoom or a teams or by and
correspondence then of course the social
worker and the jppo can be doing these
visits as as they're doing now and that
would reduce a fiscal note
considerably so so you just mentioned
the word may I I'm not seeing any Ma I'm
seeing on line 18 at the end of the the
last word of that line 18 on page three
is a shall I apologize and and and and I
just want to understand your point that
was our original yeah because that's
still a sh correct we our
original um our original internal
discussions had May um but we left it as
shall in the amendment okay could
clarification where you say that these
preferably in real time uh that we've
mentioned Microsoft teams a video
conferencing technique as would that be
an acceptable way to conduct a real time
discussion when you're talking to the
the managers and leaders and case
managers and I think that's why we
defined it asally in real yes it's very
broad we kept broad for a reason right
because it' be Zoom teams any form of um
Real Time Communication I understand
your your testimony thank you I think
there's a a definite middle ground that
the division jumped right over going
from the agreed upon amendment to this
language exactly what you just said
representative Edwards you you could
give them the option of doing a teams
but still lay out who they need to talk
to the idea
that we don't need to put it in statute
because we're going to follow what the
form says seems very disingenuous
because they don't the form would
essentially create the same
checklist intent aside if you're saying
we're going to put all that stuff into a
checklist form that says here then why
wouldn't it be appropriate to put into
law the types of people you need to talk
to which still General I you know I I
can see your concerns about the
effectiveness and whether or not we
execute in the way that you want to but
I just don't want to imply that anyone's
being disingenuous that's that's not the
way to have these conf conversations I I
think the the key point that has not yet
been clear to me and that I think is
important to discuss in this venue is
how adding a very clear outline of what
they what cpsws or jpos are required to
do how that requires additional
positions I'm not seeing that connection
I'm not hearing that connection I am
hearing that we're potentially making it
easier by giving them a guide to go by
as opposed to guessing and assuming what
they are going to do on those visits
that's the point I've not heard argu but
we're not there yet I mean to me I'm
just I'm a simple guy I'm just trying to
go line by line to understand each of
the major points of this because in the
totality of this this creates a a a
workload Benchmark that later we come
back and we talk at later what the man
Manpower would be needed to satisfy the
changes in the workload these words are
workload related not we haven't gotten
to the point where we're allocating
manpower to them yet well I I'm just
this is my question because this point
was
this piece this specific section was
represented as being reduced down to be
able to decrease the number of cpsws but
I'm not understanding that link that
that that piece hasn't been clarified
for me
yet well I mean I think we could we
could say that if you increase someone's
time at a facility and multiply that so
many times that increases one's workload
so therefore we would need additional
staff to handle
workload
um but
but excuse me but I I'm hearing both
both sides saying that you don't need
additional staff for this par particular
function so when we wrote the fiscal
note for 1573 it was as it passed the
house floor we had to stick to that so
that is where that episode of treatment
that's where that that fiscal note
ballooned as you know we did agree upon
language to reduce that remove the
episode of treatment language so that
will reduce the fiscal note but we still
because it would be an it's still if
you're expanding the visit you're
expanding their time there you're
expanding that workload that will
cause an increase in workload so
therefore it would require an increase
in a a nominal increase of
staff and that's we we agree that the
visit would be slightly longer it should
be a DI Minimus increase inre in staff
Maybe by some hours it should absolutely
eliminate that travel request because
these people are already going there and
in addition as we talked earlier with
where these facilities are
located 228 inside New Hampshire so
that's mileage you know 56 in New
England again just mileage you're
talking three children where there's any
travel and again they're still already
getting on the airplane and going there
so that's where we are un confused about
why would this require any additional
travel but frankly it should be a
dominous increase because what they're
saying is these things already happen
maybe it's happening over teams or
virtually maybe that is the solution is
build it in that way but it 22 new
people to do visits that already
happened that's where our confusion Lies
We thought taking out that episode of
treatment should completely eliminate
the request for more bodies and there
shouldn't have been any more travel to
be related so so I guess I'm now getting
confused as to the fiscal note for for
what are we talking about because right
now our fiscal note is based on how
house bill 1573 passed and the way it
passed it would require an in-person
case worker to be doing the 30-day
visits which they already do and to be
in person at these treatment team
meetings to be able to have these
conversations required under
1573 there are currently
287 youth placed in residential care 93
of those are outside of New Hampshire
and it was the case worker assigned to
the case was also How It Was Written in
uh house bills
1573 so again that's 93 outside of New
Hampshire visits which would
be a lot longer and also possibly under
multiple days because because of that
treatment team meeting needing to be in
person so if we're talking about the
fiscal impact of this amendment yes
there would be no fiscal impact for
travel because the the case workers are
already doing these 30-day visits
however they're doing these 30-day
visits with the ability to have the
treatment team meetings by live teams
Zoom or written correspondence so yes
the fiscal note would be dramatically
decreased for this amendment we haven't
done the a new fiscal note just because
how it was left uh the first day of the
finance committee so I did ask M Mr
Ripple to um he's going to work
on it's not going to be a new fiscal
note but it's going to be a so we can do
a fiscal analysis of the proposed
amendment I would suggest though that we
would like to have a a final complete
official OSS Amendment before we write
anything on that yeah okay I guess the
other thing I would like to at some
point try to get a handle on
particularly around the travel line is I
cannot remember how much is in the
existing budget for travel
and I guess that would be sort of a Mr
White question at some point not not
right now but as we go on I would like
to know how much is in the existing Bud
state budget for
travel within Madam chairman I I just
need a clarification again because I
heard the number of 96 people children
being outside of New
Hampshire and before I heard 56 in the
New England area and three
outside so where's this 96 children that
you talk
about so as of res as of March 8th 2024
there are currently 200 64 youth in New
Hampshire 88 youth in the New England
area
and I I think the confus five nationally
which is three DCF and two bcbh Susan's
including the bcbh voluntary youth Place
episode of treatment under this original
amendment that was passed by the house
correct so by striking episode of
treatment which we've all agreed to you
would lose all those bcbh Place youth
when you're talking about monthly worker
visits yes so the numbers that we
provided to you are strictly children
placed by the department of children
youth and families yes yes sorry I
apologize there are currently 176 who
are uh placed pursuant to abuse and
neglect a 169 C case and 93 uh youth
place pursuant to a juvenile resident a
juvenile case 47 chins and 46
delinquents
say yes okay so um online's 18 through
20 uh it it places an obligation on on
New Hampshire state employees that we
shall contact the following enumerated
positions but those enumerated positions
may not be under the authority of the
State of New Hampshire and and expecting
us to do something that our other party
may not have time for they're on
vacation they're sick they're in
transition I I'm a little uncomfortable
with the use of sha in that instance
because we don't have the authority to
compel their participation and so I I
think I'm comfortable with directing our
state employees to to attempt to meet
with all of them and but I don't know
that saying they shall is uh appropriate
they are required to present this
information for court reports they are
required under federal law to check in
with these providers that are providing
treatment to Children these are also
paid providers to provide this treatment
for children so they are required to
talk with those who are the custodian of
that child um so this is already a
requirement that we should be aligning
with ensuring that our statute aligns
with the federal statutes and not
limiting or reducing that in any why we
include a written correspondence because
ferally it's written correspondence
they're required to do under the federal
law order that's why we Sorry Court to
make a reasonable efforts finding to get
title 4E funding they have they have to
so so I guess I would have Rewritten the
federal law then because you can't you
you can't order somebody to do something
when they don't work for you and you
can't fire them I I mean this is just
not practical in the but but I can
understand it's federal law so I won't
assume that it makes sense and if you
want to change it you need to run for a
different
office and they are contracted providers
when we place a child as you said at the
hearing last week like we are paying
them there is an agreement whether it's
an actual contract or the certification
so they they are required to answer if
they don't I you know you're right we
don't have subpoena
power
so this is where I am actually going to
pass it off to the OCA because I have
not had much to do with the court piece
um however is there any issue with 21
through 23 I don't I I think I think
you're dismounting just a moment too
early that's just the form oh that's the
form that we agreed on basically stating
that we will create a form and a
standard operating procedure uh in in
consultation with the OCA as to the
monthly child visits as it pertains to
the previous paragraph and it was just
clarifying some language taking out Lang
language that wasn't necessary to be in
there so that was a great fund by
yep now on to page four of the
spreadsheet yeah this is the court
oversight piece that's when the court um
and Aeron had to step over to division
one because she has a bill that she
needs to speak to them about okay um so
can we move to a a different section
that doesn't involve the court we can go
on to the last section which is the
report uh page six of your spreadsheet
which is I believe
also the bottom of page five of your
Amendment starting on line
31 and that was the the department would
like to to show good faith effort
everything of that nature to to off to
issue a an annual report as to how we're
doing with this bill and so we would
like to provide that to the policy
committees that passed this legislation
as well as the children's oversight
committee um the the change is we had
just thrown it in there so we put in
consultation with the OCA because we
thought it could be a joint effort but
because of our our
natural siloed roles um they didn't feel
it was appropriate for them to be added
that's fine we we just removed their
names from it that's all yes so so two
questions here
um is there any uh uh concern about this
report being uh stripped of any uh
personal information that we we're we're
doing we're writing this report
consistent with privacy expectations
absolutely our our department does not
issued second second question uh in the
list of those that you would distribute
to um
was consideration made to providing a
copy to the uh joint oversight Committee
of Health and Human Services uh we have
a chairman here from that committee who
who might have an opinion but this this
feels to me from watching you that you
would like a copy of this report as well
he's actually also chair of the children
and family law which is committee which
is the one that passed this bill and
that's why that that was so they didn't
think us is what you're
[Laughter]
saying correct right we we can add you
if you would if you would like it's not
just me but I think in the future we
want the the I what's the official name
the joint health and human
services I would also know the OA should
probably be added to that list too we
got taken out of nope we're not no I
think because I think we thought we were
working with you obviously you would
have a copy yes
okay the OCA
and services oversight committee okay
I'll find the
title so that's
it okay that's it well that's well we
have the court oversight piece as well
yes and I think we're just going to have
to wait until Aaron comes back um her to
go through it with us okay so maybe
we'll go on a a little break break so so
do you want to talk to them about the
timeline that we're on what we're trying
to
do yeah um Monday I think it's Monday
we're have we are meeting in full
division yep and at that point are we I
division three has a work session on
Monday afternoon yes okay right in our
full division right yeah and Friday and
then again we'll be voting on Friday
okay will actually be and on Monday
we're going to come up with the we'll
bring forth an amendment to yeah mon
Monday Monday is the last day to have
moving Parts you know uh if we if we're
still yet another amendment there's a
little bit of time but it can't be so
significant because we have to vote on
Friday of next week right right so we're
I think we're working really hard at
figuring out how to say yes to each
other here so okay
it would probably be helpful
if you know if there are places that the
department and the off the child
Advocates office could work together to
see you know if we can come to some
agreement about some of these pieces
that there seems to be a lot of
controversy about and try to try to work
through some of those and um so that we
can be ready for so we can be ready for
Monday have something for Monday right
Monday and we're done once we have that
Kevin can start to do his fiscal
analysis for us and that will be that
will be really helpful to get that done
because we're going to need that in
order to talk to the um the rest of the
division about the bill and the
cost okay great do you have more
questions I don't think so okay we're
good thank you good thank
you
we're in recess for a few minutes and I
I'll go see if I can I think maybe Kevin
stepped over to see how much longer um
aon's going to be I could use a
moment yeah I I imagine you will be
right
back
e
some going to call us back to order on
the sustainability issue whether it it's
and I and I think that's very important
seems like a sidebar conversation it is
okay it is totally
sidebar good okay back to the judicial
yeah when we get
Eric um so eror and Creed from the uh
from the I
here and can help us go through those
sections and this is the first time
we've heard from the court so
um yes please yes that would be great
and then um I'm really looking for their
response you know sure what's um sorry
so this section of the bill is sub L the
same as what passed the house last month
the changes are in some tweaks of
wording we worked closely um with the
juvenile reform policy Group which is
made up of a number of community
advocacy groups including folks that
represent children in these cases so New
Hampshire legal assistance uh children's
Law Center
DRC so most of the changes
between representative Pearson
um that's not the right
one amendment that pass the house
0427 to this amendment proposed
amendment is weaks in language as far as
aligning with the federal
standards so it would be language like
instead of saying appropriate placement
the federal guidelines require it to be
the most effective and appropriate level
of care for the child in the least
restrictive environment so it
essentially means the same thing they
just wanted the words to be the same as
what is required under federal statute
so that's what the changes are
substantively um the reason for this
portion of the bill and I think I
mentioned earlier this uh section also
passed attached to s417 yesterday in
Senate Judiciary because that bill also
talks about residential
placement if the goal is to reduce the
number of children in residential
placement and to make sure that that
residential placement is tailored to the
needs of that specific child for
shortterm needs-based care the judicial
oversight was a big part of it of well
who who orders that placement it's the
court who's going to order that kid out
of placement it's the court we had also
gotten some feedback from judges in the
Judiciary after bledo that there was a
feeling that they didn't
really know that much about residential
placements particularly the ones further
away the ones that they weren't
frequently placing at they were only
getting the information presented by the
the division and it it wasn't as
thorough as they would like as far as
you know the level of assessment really
um having the terminology required by
federal law as far as when you can place
a child in as we talked about that most
restrictive setting so this just sort of
sets up the layers of evaluation and the
information that the court needs to make
that decision and again from a liability
point of view if a Court's making an
order we want to make sure that on the
record is substantial information of why
that order placing a child in a very
restrictive placement is necessary so
this is sort of split into before the
kid gets placed now why while the kid's
placed and how we're getting the kid out
of placement one other um tweak we did
make after talking with Ain was just
sort of allowing an emergency escape
Clause like you asked about earlier what
if this kid needs to go into emergency
placement allows the court a little bit
of time to be able to get the
information after the fact if the
Department's making an emergency
placement more in the Juvenile Justice
Arena because those placements literally
can happen in the middle of the night
and they call a court in the middle of
the night or judge so the first section
is prior to placing unless it's an
emergency the types of assessment ments
and the findings um being that the
child's needs cannot be met in a homik
setting and then what they are required
uh to meet this amendment also requires
a little bit of language around what the
school districts need to be doing
because there is both state and federal
law about the school districts still
need to be requiring um education for
these children in residential placements
particularly in that special ed Arena so
um that's the differences between the
two was just sort of TW tweaking some of
that language overarching though is this
desire to get children a make sure
they're in the right placement first and
then get them out of that placement as
quickly as possible when it's
appropriate so I think um the fiscal
note relates to the The increased
hearing So currently children in
placement get hearings every 90 days
under 169 CBD those are regular review
hearings so under this provision a child
that goes into res presidential
placement would get hearings every 60
days unless the very specific um
circumstance where the child or the
child's representative doesn't support
the residential treatment program level
of care or the guardian at lium which is
currently in law objects to that
placement um then it would be 30 days
and again the hope is these more
frequent reviews lead to the child
coming out of residential placement
quicker
as soon as they're out of residential
placement it goes back to the 90day
review this so this only applies to this
287 kids we have been talking about that
are placed by dcyf under 169 BC or D
into a residential placement so out of
the 1300 kids in care dcyf care only 287
of them is who this would apply to and
only for that limited period that
they're in
placement
hello my name is Aaron krian I'm the
general counsel for the judicial branch
say say your last name again crean c r e
e g
n I've sometimes heard it said it's
Irish for horse from over
speaking there I looked in a nam's book
and it said it comes from the word in
Irish for horse from over speaking uh so
I don't know what that says so are you
an attorney I am an attorney
so I I don't know it must have been bad
for that to end up being our name um but
there were other interpretation there
were other
translations uh so I I thank you for the
opportunity to speak on this I I know I
don't appear before you as much in
division three and so uh if you'll
forgive me I I often point out and I I
haven't spoken with folks as much that
the courts uh generally don't take
policy positions on bills we do point
out Court Administration or enforcement
issues but there are a lot of different
ways to solve this policy issue to
address it and we usually would not say
do this or do that because that's the
role of the legislature you're hearing
from a lot of the interested parties and
we're happy to provide technical
feedback but um we don't defend or
oppose different bills we just bring
whatever you find useful to your
evaluation and and then you tell us uh
how you would like us to handle these
cases uh so the the fiscal note that we
submitted was based on uh the about 300
number of residential placements which
Osa is referring to I think it was 297
in their last report so uh you know
rounded to 300 that if that moves from
90 days to 30 days instead of having
1,200 hearings a year you would have
3600 hearings a year um I understand
that the L there's maybe just a
difference of opinion on How likely it
is that they would be a hearing every 60
days versus every 30 days as I read the
amendment that passed the house um there
is not a standard that needs to be met
in order for there to be a 30-day
hearing so it is just if any party
requests to have a 30-day hearing I
think uh you I I don't have a specific
number of how frequent this is but I did
talk to a few different judges that do
these cases frequently to get at least
their anecdotal sample and uh what I
heard was that it is almost always the
case that certainly an abuse and neglect
case that the parents are seeking the
return of their child they have an
attorney who's paid for by the judicial
Council so they're not resource Limited
in their ability to file a motion or
request this hearing uh so I do expect
that and and it's also my understanding
that children generally want to return
to the community that they're coming
from uh so they are seeking a foster
placement as opposed to residential
placement uh so it it is my expectation
that it would be much more likely than
not that there would be 30-day review
because there would be someone objecting
to the continued residential placement
if not the child or their representative
then one of the parents potentially
seeking uh the return of the child so I
I don't I I think that those C's view is
that if you move from 90 to 60 it's only
a 50% increase in hearings six a year
versus four a year and it is it is
really my expectation that it would be
closer to 12 um I'm not trying to
frustrate the underlying policy
objective of the bill which is to get
more judicial involvement more hearings
more timely more process by suggesting
anything that would frustrate that
policy objective but if it is a part of
the policy objective to have fewer
30-day hearings there are things that
you could do you could say only for good
cause have every 30 days or otherwise
it's 60 days um that may not be enough
to meet what's being sought in this bill
but it's it is my expectation when I
made this uh estimate that it would be
2400 additional hearings a year which at
a rate of about an hour and a half
assuming a judge takes about an hour and
a half to prepare do the hearing and
issue all necessary rulings would be to
full-time judicial
officers um um the staff estimate is
just based on a weighted case load study
that we did in July of 2022 that showed
that abuse and neglect in residential
placement cases take a very large amount
of clerk time they're confidential
they're paper intensive there are hear a
lot of hearings um so they just happen
to take up a lot of clerk times that's
based on our historical understanding of
how much clerical work goes into these
types of hearings um it is a big ground
estimate so it's just taking the number
of hearings times a a guess at about an
hour and a half of judicial time and a a
a past standard on how often we use how
much clerical time we use in these case
types uh so that's how we arrived at
this estimate and and there are
certainly ways that you could reduce the
cost but I I don't want to suggest
something that would also frustrate the
policy
objective okay so um let let's let's
back up to the beginning of what you
were saying Miss kin I
I this
division understands the Department of
Health and Human Service really really
well what we do not understand because
we're not exposed to it is the way that
the Judiciary works and your explanation
to how you did your workload count is
all great I I would just encourage you
in this instance in this bill um to to
to be uh to give yourself permission to
think a little bit differently uh we I
know what I don't know and I don't know
how the judicial aspect of this works
and I like the idea that you support
that we want to maintain a policy
objective but but what I'm what I need
and what I hope you're you're you're
comfortable with is to um help us take a
look at the processes that this law
would uh Define and
impose uh and see if there's uh maybe
another way to do it in which uh we can
still maintain quality and and uh and
appr appropriateness of the the timing
and in result of the
decisions and but maybe do it in a a
more a less restrictive more flexible
Manner and I think I heard you say
something about um you know that that
maybe there may be an alternative to
where we can do some of this on an exp
parte or an emergency
basis um as opposed to as as
prescriptive as it is and I I I don't
want to put words in your mouth I I I be
I just am not fully understanding the
the what your workload is and if there's
a a smart way to change the workload
requirements as this law would do while
still protecting the the
children thank you for the question I
think that uh Miss massio was mentioning
that the there was an emergency
exception put in at our request just
because we weren't certain what the
legislature's intention in an emergency
situation where we could not do this
full process um where we have to place a
child maybe that day that night and we
might not have assessments from when
they were eight uh you know all
assessments we might not have the
documentation to the level that you
would desire to have in a Fuller and
more uh planned premeditated hearing and
I see that that was added and that's
appreciated because we just want to have
the guidance of the legislature on what
we do if not this full
process
P page three line
27 added except in emergency
situations I would note though that it
looks like the other language I proposed
a DHHS did not make
it put him
find um
oh for the rest of the emergency so
there's more to the emergency I just
noticed while I was looking there's
another paragraph for the emergency
situation which would tell them what to
do then um so and it it sort of mirrors
uh language in HB 535 which the house
passed related to um giving counsel to
children in residential so what it says
and I can give you this language in the
case of an emergency necessitating
immediate placement to make that all Ed
the department shall notify the court
within two business days of such
placement in order for the court to make
all those findings in the paragraph
one so so I would ask the smart people
to to see if there's a way because I'm
just looking at it as a workload issue
in theory is if we re reduced the
prescriptive uh aspects of what we must
do through the court system um with um a
a more responsive flexible emergency
component uh then that would possibly be
a way in which we could take some of the
uh overhead costs out while still
preserving what we're trying to do which
is to give good judicial review of each
kid's case when the kids's case needs to
be reviewed so we we definitely have a
suggestion
unfortunately we had not gotten to talk
to Aaron before so I hear how they're
interpreting that 30-day piece which
sounds like the big bulk of the issue I
think two things we could easily do we
had intended for the objection to be
really that the residential placement
doesn't meet the child's needs versus
just anybody get to say I don't want
them in residential care so we can
certainly take the any party out and
make it clear that it's when the child
or the child's representative which
would potentially be an attorney under
those other bills says court it's not
meeting the level of care that all these
assessments are saying a more technical
issue not just I don't want to go to
residential care because that was not
our intent but I do understand why it's
being read that way I think another um
good solution to to again cut that cost
without losing protection is if the
objection is made that you're not
meeting the level of care have the
hearing at 30 days and then after that
every 60 not have it keep being 30 which
would again reduce the cost
substantially um I would say so
currently anybody can file an xart day
motion whenever they want if somebody
sees an issue particularly if children
in residential care are granted
attorneys as pass the house in
January you can always file an expart
Day saying something bad is happening um
and we hope that people do I think um
the fear of that the other side of the
liability issue though is again we're
having all these conversations about the
the harm caused by residential care if
you wait for something bad to happen and
then file something now something bad
has happened so um I think we're trying
to balance the having increased
oversight so nothing bad does happen
with not overbearing on the system so to
that point uh we're we're we're
increasing the amount of surveillance on
the part of the case
managers uh I would assume that uh the
the greatest future source of expart
motions would be from the case
managers because they they would be the
ones explicitly looking to see if
something is a foul of the certification
and
just
decency having been a DC attorney I
would not assume that I think if a
worker saw something going on they would
probably go to their supervisor maybe to
bcbh typically the division and maybe
Susan has a different take on this
wouldn't CP workers can move kids around
without court order so I don't think
they would be filing a motion they would
start investigating new placements and
move the kid um I would Envision it'd be
the child's attorney potentially that
might file emergency motions based on
what they're perceiving as their clients
needs okay but I I so this is a new area
to me so I'm sorry if this is really
basic but uh do do every does every kid
have an attorney I I I would imagine
this is a really um under underserved
population and they don't have attorneys
running around why why wouldn't we want
the case managers as part of their
duties to potentially file a judicial
review request right and I think overall
I feel like we keep leaving out Juvenile
Justice with these cases so with
Juvenile Justice yes every Chin's case
every delinquency case they have an
attorney and that meets um 93 of those
kids are juvenile
kids as Lisa pointed out there are two
bills that are um moving forward uh in
the legislature this term that would
allow for a a child that not only have
um a casa G appointed at the time of a
CPS case a child protection case or 169
C case they will also have may have an
attorney appointed to them and if their
imp placement or placement is
contemplated they shall have an attorney
appointment to them okay so that's good
education thank you uh do we currently
or do we anticipate having the case
managers also be aware of their kids
attorney so that the case
manager is encouraged to contact the
attorney to if they see something wrong
is that is that part of the process or
or it's a dumb thing to do what is it no
and I think that's what written to both
bills how if placement is contemplated
an attorney shall be represented uh
appointed and they shall represent them
at treatment meetings as well correct
similar to JJ they are able to if they
choose to do so I would say um you
coming from a state where all children
and child welfare worked in the state of
Massachusetts all children and child
welfare were assigned attorneys and yes
it was the responsibility of the case
workers to communicate with those
children's attorneys make sure that they
were aware of any concerns update them
if there was something that they learned
that the attorney did not gather the
information first so if we're looking at
best practice if 535 continues to move
forward and we are looking at best
practice best practice would be that
they are there is some form of open
communication between both parties so so
in the prior sections that we reviewed
today there was no mention of of the
responsibility of the case manager to
also conduct periodic conversations with
the attorney neither periodic nor
exigent so I'm just wondering did we
miss something that we should put in
here no the reason why that isn't in
there currently um in part is because
we're talking about right now it's only
speciic to Juvenile Justice cases um
because 535 is still in motion so if
that is to pass fully through then at
that point that's something that
typically would be developed in a
standard operating procedure policy for
the division of how they manage that
contact with the attorney
but it we have not aligned in a sense
where we can say we're confident we know
100% that bill is going to pass and so
we're going to incorporate pieces of
that bill tied back into this so
I I don't know how you look at it but I
look at it that this bill has to stand
alone I'm not going to make any
assumption that some parallel Bill
somewhere is going to pass I I want this
bill to be right what regardless of what
the Senate thinks they're doing so if if
if if there's some aspect that you think
is going to be taken by
535 that maybe we ought to be putting in
here as well then I I'm I'm open to that
because I don't want to assume 5 35
passes I think
currently at the review hearings and and
would be required for new new review
hearings workers produce reports with
information about all the contacts one
of the reasons we want that more
thorough form is so that those monthly
visits are are more detailed but that
report goes out to every party in the
case so it would go to the cost it does
now go to the casa goes to the parents
attorneys if a child has an attorney
under 35 it would go to those folks too
I you know it like cassandre said the
kind of in between communication that's
more informal via email or phone is sort
of under standard operating procedure
and the workers have their own dcyf
attorneys as well so like they have an
attorney internal to DCF that they could
also raise it to hey I went to this
facility really concerned so there there
is also a process that the division
could file something as well and just to
clarify a little bit more so with with
CPS with one 69 C cases there's an
appointed G typically a casa worker at
first instance if there's a conflict or
they aren't able to serve that child
than a private gal is appointed that
private J and the casa or the casa G is
meeting in person with the child every
30 days as well as of now there are
what's called 30 uh nine 90day Court
review hearings with CPS they're
typically called the three-month Court
review hearing the six Monon the 9month
leading to the 12-month permanency
hearing at each of those review hearings
a court report is um presented to the
court dcyf does their own court report
and that's where they're attaching
updates from the residential placement
that was referred to earlier in terms of
the written correspondence that is
attached to that court report G's are
independently doing their own Court
review Court re uh sorry review hearing
court report as well giving updates as
well to the child their wants their
needs where they're at in the uh in the
treatment
process with jppo it's a little
different they have was typically 90day
it's called 90day Court review court
court hearings Court review hearings
where again the jppo is presenting to
the court uh updates as to what has been
going on at the facility how is the
child doing where are they not and
there's also Court oversight pursuant to
169 c19 that the legislature passed in
2021 placement and qualified Residential
Treatment programs to align with federal
law so this law uh as was spoken today
is a little bit different from that in
which in that law the assessment is
reviewed um within 60 days of placement
um for any child plac in a qualified
residential treatment program as toine
the federal Family First prevention
service actor 2017 the court shall order
an assessment to be completed within 30
days of placement so now it's going to
happen before placement right that first
part of the statute says prior to
existing law this is existing law passed
by the legislature on July 9th uh went
into effect July 9th 2029 that's 169 c19
F placement in a qualified residential
PR treatment program and then the court
reviews that assessment and issues an
order approving the placement or
changing the placement within 60 days of
placement and that is
um court form 3207 motion for judicial
judicial determination in 169 B CD cases
regarding current residential treatment
program so there is already Court
oversight as to residential placement in
align with the family First Act again
because I'm a simple guy was was that a
way of saying that the fiscal note
saying we need nine new uh judicial
positions to support this workload that
that is that we may not need it because
we already are supposed to have
it this is happening um typically by
motion practice and then the court
reviews the placement uh the C What's
called the comprehens so I'm looking for
kind of a yes or
no so so so if it's already an existing
law and those obligations are already
imposed what this fiscal Noe is meant to
do for this new amendment is to take a
look at the incremental costs the new
costs associated with going above and
beyond the existing law that's what this
fiscal no it's intended to do I can
clarify that piece for you um no because
the so the law that um Susan just read
for us is specific to qualified
residential treatment program and that
is tied to the title for money so that's
the federal money that's why it's tied
to the the language that's in the family
first Prevention Services act it is
intended only for facilities that are
going to be provided or requesting the
title for E funds not all children in
residential placements placed by the
state of New Hampshire are in qualified
residential treatment program so what
we're looking to do is capture all of
the children placed under 169 BC and D
that's only a small portion of
that the the estimate that we did was
based on the understanding that because
there's an option for any party to raise
a 30-day hearing without there being a
specific standard that we would be
moving from a deao 90 to a deao 30
tripling our hearings um going from
about 1,200 to about 3600 what I
understand is that it it may be possible
to achieve the policy objective uh while
reducing that number of hearings and if
that's the case it would absolutely
lower the estimate that we have and and
if I may add um so we were looking for a
language we scoured many states to look
for a language that already existed in
law this is language that was pulled
from I believe this specifically was
from the state of New Jersey um so that
is just pulling it as it is written
there talking about the impact that that
will have specifically on New Hampshire
and the courts we see the ability to
make those changes that Lisa mentioned
we had not had many opportunities to
speak with Erin prior to this so
apologies for that Erin um but I do
think we C we would have had no problem
making those changes had we been aware
of the impact on the courts and had some
of these conversations and same with our
request for additional attorneys because
we were going with what's not in
practice which is the um uh every 60-day
review hearing and the possibility of
every 30-day so either way it would be
by minimum an an additional
1,722
hearings with
1573 and at the maximum about
3,444 additional hearings and that's
where we came up with our need for
additional attorneys there's no attorney
request in this bill I I I didn't
understand that last
comment as far as my review of this bill
there's no request for attorneys in this
you have another there is none in the
fiscal work
sheeet okay so so again because I'm
simple it sounded to me uh Miss krian
that in just having this conversation
you're comfortable with a different
interpretation of what's been written
such that it reduces the workload you
thought may be incumbent upon the
department I I again I don't want to put
words in your mouth but did I hear that
right um I don't think I can say yes or
no but I just want to make sure I
understand your statement um I think
that it would need to be changed in the
way that it is written in order to
reduce the number of hearings but that
was my next question and and and and to
get your interpretation so that there's
no confusion do we need to change the
language and can you participate in
helping do good that's great
absolutely yeah if you can work with the
child Advocates office to certainly get
that okay that'd be great thank
you
question okay let's have a technical
question okay so um because I I come
back to this idea that a lot of
decisions need to be made in a resource
constrained environment and so when I'm
reading on page four lines 10 and
11 it it it it it basically says that
that the decision for the child's
residential treatment program is meant
to be providing the most effective and
appropriate level of
care and and so the question of
availability jumps in and so so I wonder
if if maybe we could add a couple of
words to to to to make sure that the the
decision is most effective and
appropriate given available
Alternatives that is the language that
is from federal Family First Prevention
Services act and so so the feds got one
right they did
they did and so we would not want we
have that reflected in our language then
since we're trying to emulate the feds
no so we have so that that what is
written here now the most effective um
and appropriate level of care for the
child in the least restrictive
environment that language is from the
the federal language and so we are
making sure that that is consistent and
if we added something outside of that
such as an exception due to resources we
would not be aligning with the
fedal and then they would not give us
M well if they caught
us little liability issue
there pretty much Kevin could you talk
to us for a minute about um um when we
go forward forward with this there are
additional at least in the fisal note
they talk about additional um staff and
Appropriations would that would need to
be it seems like authorized in the bill
right which were not previously that's
correct and the bill is introduced there
were no Appropriations and no
authorizations for new positions um
there are now in the bill as amended by
the house for the HHS piece but not for
the judicial branch um and I think
those positions and cost estimates uh in
the bill as passed by the house are
different than what HHS is now
predicting and will be different from
what they predict in response to this
amendment that's being worked on now so
um so we'll get some new numbers from
that and we'll include them in the
fiscal analysis and likewise with the
judicial
branch um as far as what should be in
the amendment that's being developed now
for an appropriation I don't know how
quickly we'll have that number um I
don't know for the time being perhaps
you should consider including a
placeholder um that could be with a
number that could be added later um
that's really up
to how quickly the department can get me
some
information um I don't know that
everybody heard uh representative
Edwards um letting me know that we need
to have an official Amendment drafted by
OS by Monday yeah so that the division
as a whole can um act upon this on this
bill and be ready to uh go on for a
Friday we're going to vote on Friday yes
no later then so so I'm going to need I
will go over to OS and have it drafted
but I am going to need all these pieces
from all of you okay right additional
question oh represent PR has yes um on
the development of a file management
system for
$500,000 that seems awfully high and I
would just like to get some
clarification on
that for for the work that's being
done in the
um apologize Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer Department of Health
and Human Services um representative
priest um you're you're looking at the
original fiscal note the IT team has
actually gone back and and further
investigated that and right now they are
estimating that that's going to be a
higher cost
um correct because either it would be an
inhouse um customization or it would
potentially be an off-the-shelf
product but I can have uh Dave weers
come out out to the next working session
he's Our IT director to speak to the
specifics of why those costs would be so
high if you'd
like do you have a estimate um Mr White
of what those costs would be the most
recent estimate I've received from Dave
is is approximately a million
dollars the other alternative is to
continue to use more of a Windows folder
based system um the the cost repres
presented there would be to develop a a
true uh certification system um because
I think what's important to remember
here is we're basically taking on almost
like a joint commission type function
where you're going into an organization
to certify them we don't have any
existing it system that we could use to
you know run numbers and case File and
followup and all these other things it
would have to be completely manual um
and it' probably be a word excel access
based system otherwise
so so can I just say that I I I think
what the general policy is is that we're
possible we would rather rely on a
vendor that has expertise in a developed
system than to have an employee
basically do a roll your own with
Microsoft tools not only because that
person's not a subject matter expert and
has a steep learning curve but because
uh then we be become obligated for every
Microsoft update and if that smart
person goes and gets another job then we
don't know what's in the system and we
can't maintain it so so the I think the
cost i' I'd be most interested in is uh
and this is for you to representative
priest i' I'd be most interested in what
uh the estimate would be to procure uh
an off-the-shelf product with a vendor
support than to roll our
own and and and and that's the updated
million dollars um that we've submitted
in the fiscal note worksheet for the
amended
version I I block Kevin because Kevin
had something he wanted to
say so just as a followup what have you
been using now in the current system
because this you're supposed to be doing
this already and how are you sharing
this information and and inputting
it is this a question for DHS J
yes we're gonna have a question for you
oh no I'm about to shortly be towed are
you sure I can't
uh take that question by writing no okay
I'll say I'll try to be quick so we do
everything manually now they're all in
our shared Windows File
Explorer separate folders one of the
reason reasons why it is highly
burdensome for us to get records to the
OCA and others are who are interested is
it's a manual process um we are swimming
in different Excel spreadsheets that um
the data doesn't match so it's really
hard for us to put that together to get
aggregate data we have providers sending
in monthly workbook files in Excel that
are not analyzed and aggregated either
so we have a whole bunch of manual
places
that really don't talk to each other and
can't give us that big picture system
and give us the ability to share it
easily um and and that's what we'd need
if we're increasing the number of visits
the number of reports right now we get
things by facts we scan them we put them
in files and it's um it's very slow and
tedious so so I would imagine that that
creates at least three problems you know
you you got an access control issue who
who's going to get access to this system
you you have audit Trail issues because
it gets to be confusing who accessed
what information at what point and then
you get a sharing issue where if the OCA
wants access to the database or the
Judiciary does then it's much more
difficult to arrange sharing those are
the three problems I would guess you're
having yeah additionally we could use
this type of system to allow providers
to upload certification information more
quickly to speed up their certification
process just as a followup um so are is
your presence system something that
other departments can view and no
so thank
you other departments cannot access it
it's
it no it's all within HHS and certain
parts of HHS like parts of DCF that need
that information can access those
folders but it's it's all very manual
and individual by folder and by file
it's I wouldn't call it a
system any
other no one else wants to talk okay
okay I I felt like I I I stopped Miss
krian from saying something you got oh
what I was saying is that I'm shortly
about to be
towed oh needs to go get out there
before before but I will stay here and
pay that ticket if you have any more
questions for the judicial bre okay I
think you should go and get your
car I want to thank everyone for coming
and helping us get through this and I
guess we'll see each other again I hope
before Monday that I will hear from you
okay
thanks
e